this video is brought to you by me
Corrado weird zebra sex mask I got a
weird zebra sex mask or more accurately
a new channel I'm doing called business
plays it's business theme topics like
trillion dollar bills crazy pyramid
schemes and the biggest business scams
in history it's sort of like the content
that I make here but it's a bit more
relaxed it's a bit more freestyle please
do check it out through the link in the
description below consider subscribing
and let me know what you think and let's
get into it
[Music]
this tremendous tale of samurai loyalty
and honor goes by several names it is
usually referred to as the Aiko G cone
in Japan translated as the a coincidence
or sometimes the a coven detta it has
been featured so prominently in Japanese
literature and Kabuki theater that it
spawned its own genre
shushing gora or the treasure of loyal
retainers this genre only includes
fictional stories based on this
historical event in the West we know it
as the forty-seven Ronin the story of 47
early 18th century samurai who lose
their master and embark on an ambitious
journey to avenge the unjust death of
their Lord the tale first made its way
to our parts over a hundred years after
it took place courtesy of isaac titsingh
a dutch merchant and scholar
who did business with the Tokugawa
Shogunate of Japan on behalf of the
Dutch East India Company the event was
later popularized by British writer and
former diplomat Abie Mitford who
featured it prominently in his
anthropology book tales of old Japan
this has become the definitive version
of the story in the West and the one we
will mostly be relying on today modern
scholars a pine that while Mitford did
do plenty of research for his book and
presents a lot of details and
descriptions he also had a habit of
overdramatizing some of the more
climactic parts to make for a more
exciting story even so today we bring
you as best we know it the tale of the
forty-seven Ronin
our story starts at the very beginning
of the 18th century to help you
understand it better we should quickly
present a few concepts about feudal
Japan at that time the country at an
emperor but his role was mostly symbolic
the true power was held by the Shogun
because he had command evident military
in 1701 when the events took place
Japan was almost halfway through the
Tokugawa period also known as the Edo
period because that is where the
Shogunate established at seat of power
while the emperor was still based in
Kyoto Edo is better known today as Tokyo
although Higashiyama was the Emperor of
Japan back then the man actually in
charge was Tokugawa suni oh she's the
fifth Shogun of the Tokugawa dynasty and
the Shogun exerted his path throughout
the lands with the help of 300 feudal
lords called I note one of these daimyo
and the one pertinent to us today was
Asano nagging Orie the third member of
the Asano clan to rule over the a code
name in 1701 he and another noble named
Kamakura chika were tasked with
organizing a reception for some of the
Emperor's ambassadors who were visiting
Edo Castle as part of their service
known as the sang King caught I sang
King caught I was a policy developed by
the Tokugawa shoguns to help them keep
an eye on their feudal lords and to
minimize their resources so they didn't
get any funny ideas about revolting
basically it meant that the daimyo had
to split their time between their own
domains and Edo Castle for several
months at a time every feudal lord took
his family and his retainers and went to
live in Edo where he served the Shogun
directly his family ends most
importantly his heir stayed in Edo
whenever the daimyo left look after his
fiefdom and they were basically hostages
of the Shogun to ensure that the Lord
behaved himself
moreover the Edo residence of the Lord
plus all the tasks yet to perform for
the Shogun while he was there were all
paid out of pockets which meant less
money to raise an army that could be
used against the Shogun
anyway it was a sorrow nagging or ease
time to perform his sang
King got high in order for him and kamae
to organize a proper reception for the
Imperial ambassadors they needed lessons
in court etiquette and protocol from one
of the Shogun's high officials a man
named kira yoshinaka who was essentially
a master of ceremonies of course for his
services Kira expected gifts and
monetary compensation Kira and the two
daimyo did not get along we're not
really sure why that was Milford said
that the Edo official was a man greedy
of money who wasn't happy with the gifts
he received other sources said he was an
arrogance man who treated the two Nobles
with contempt and ridicule either way
his actions and attitude became too much
to bear but it was actually the other
daimyo Lord kamae who first decided that
he wanted to kill Kira he announced his
intention to his retainers during a
meeting saying that he had made up his
mind and the following day he would
strike down kira after the first insult
and then would suffer the consequences
his servants had no choice but to accept
their masters decisions but his
counselor looked for another solution he
realized that the only way to get
through to the official was with a bribe
so he collected all the money he could
and rode off that night to Cara's
mansion there kamae servant presented
him with a thousand ounces of silver
plus another hundred for his retainers
the bribe had a miraculous effect on
Kira the next day he apologized to kamae
for his conduct and from then on treated
him with respect his behavior towards
Asano however remained unchanged if
anything it became even worse as kira
was now angry that the lord from a KO
didn't follow his fellow nobleman's
example for a long time Asano nagging
Orie took the insults in silence but he
eventually reached his limit at one
point kara pointed his foot and said
that the ribbon of his sock had come
untied and told the Lord to bend down
and tie for him although burning with
rage Asano did this but afterwards Kira
continued to mock him saying that he was
a clumsy country boy who did it
improperly and that was enough Asano
took out a small sword called Oaxaca
Sachi and attacked the official but only
mangled a cart on Kira's face before the
guard separated them even though the
injuries were minor the consequences
were grave although he deserved it Kira
was still a powerful official of the
show
not to mention that any kinds of
violence was forbidden at Edo castle
Asano nagging Orie was condemned to
commit seppuku ritual suicide by
disembowelment his death also meant the
death of his clan his lands and goods
were confiscated while his retainers
became Ronin meaning samurai without
masters revenge for Asano's death had
been expressly forbidden by the Shogun
but for some of his men this mattered
little the Accademia had hundreds of
retainers but forty-seven of the most
loyal banded together with the intent of
seeking vengeance on behalf of their
former master led by Asano's former
principal counselor or each occurrence
Suki or she oh and they became over
forty-seven Ronin
now Kira may have been corrupt arrogant
sends a reprehensible man but he was
certainly no fool he realized that even
with the Shogun's decree some of Asano's
former men might feel duty-bound to seek
revenge
therefore he surrounded himself at all
times by a host of guards provided by a
daimyo named yasugi sama who is his
father-in-law the Ronin could have
attempted to take on Kira and his men in
open battle they were all quite prepared
to die for their vengeance since they
realized that even if they were
successful they would most likely be
executed anyway however what they could
not risk was Kara getting away during
the fight as they would almost certainly
get only one shot at getting him
therefore they needed the edo official
to get rid of his bodyguards and for
that they needed to convince him that
there was no threat to achieve their
goal their own in all pretended to get
on with their lives and go their
separate ways like many of the other
retainers who once worked for the Asano
clan they found new professions son
became merchants others became
carpenters some even posed as monks out
of all of them Orie she went to the
greatest lengths to lay a Kira's
suspicion as Asano's most trusted
servant he was also the one official
feared the most because it was expected
of him to seek revenge instead Orie she
relocated to Kyoto with his family where
he became a drunkard and a womanizer he
knew he had Kira's spies on his tail
watching everything he did and reporting
back to Edo so he had to dedicate
himself completely to this new role
regardless of the
brought upon him he would spend his days
in bars and brothels stumbling drunk
through the streets and causing a scene
so that everyone would know what had
become of Oishi a once proud samurai of
the Akko daimyo the most notorious
incidents happens with a man from
Satsuma who recognized Dewey she passed
out in the street disgusted with him he
called him fool and Craven and unworthy
of the name of a samurai he then kicked
and spat on him Oh is she accepted
everything but he then went even farther
his wife although she knew of her
husband's plan could no longer stand the
shame she begged him to show some
restraints but this only served to spur
him on even further he concluded that a
man in his position would likely be
abandoned by his family because his wife
knew it was all an act she did not want
to actually leave her husband so oh is
she left her and told her to take the
children to only his eldest Hui Shi chin
Cara's stayed by his side as he was one
of the forty-seven Ronin and so oh is
she carried on meanwhile all of his
actions were reported back to Kira and
eventually his dedication paid off after
over a year and a half had passed the
official started to feel safe again
believing that Asano's former samurai
had left their past lives behind them
vengeance in all he sent most of his
guards back to their lord and once again
was only protected by his own much
smaller retinue while he was giving his
oscar-worthy performance some of the
other Ronin did their part by getting
jobs in Edo in anticipation of the
attack they observed the layout of
Kara's house looked for places to enter
an exit studied his movements and
gathered information about his retainers
they also started smuggling and
stockpiling weapons which they had to do
in great secrecy as we mentioned
previously not everyone could just walk
around Edo armed to the teeth not to
mention that it would have surely raised
a few eyebrows if Asano's former
retainers who were now supposed to be
craftsmen and merchants
started equipping themselves like
samurai again things were going pretty
smooth earlier one scarer sent his army
away and she was no longer being spied
on it was all just a matter of waiting
for the opportune time
[Music]
almost two years have passed since the
death of a son a nagging Orie but on
December the 14th 1702 the 47 Ronin were
ready to avenge their former master it
was a cold snowy day and the winds
howled with fury the Ronin lurked
patiently in the shadows waiting for
midnight sir launched their assault the
night before they held one final feast
together as the plan was to turn
themselves in and accept the death
sentence that was sure to come of course
this would be after they chopped off
Kira's head and delivered it as an
offering to their master's tomb the
signal for the attack was the beating of
a drum all the Ronin also carried a
shrill whistle with them that they would
blow if they found and had slayed the
target the samurai had split into two
groups one was led by Yi XI and would
charged through the front gate while a
smaller group led by his son would cover
the side entrance to ensure that Kira
could not slip through their grasp they
knew there would be collateral damage
killing Kira's retainers was unavoidable
as they would surely try to protect
their master however he urged his
brethren to avoid hunting any women
children old men and other physically
helpless persons that they might run
into on the night in question the Ronin
leader even sent one of his companions
to garre's neighbours to inform them of
who they were and what they intended to
do the messenger assured the neighbors
that they were neither thieves nor
ruffians and that no harm would come to
them as long as they did not try to
interfere indeed the neighbors found
these terms perfectly agreeable and none
of them tried to come to the officials
aid because well none of them liked him
well at least that's how its portrayed
in every story
some historians indicated that the
master of ceremonies may have been more
popular in real life in his home town
because he helped develop farmland and
build dikes with the matter of the
neighbors settled it was finally time to
strike
who is she began beating his drum and
the Ronin storms the house of kira
yoshinaka ten of the samurai climbed the
rooftops took out their bows and kept
watch on the courtyard to make sure
nobody escaped to call for
reinforcements meanwhile the frontal
assault team led by Oishi broke into the
main hall where it was greeted by ten of
Kira's soldiers a fight ensued but the
Ronin were more prepared and determined
compared to the retainers who had just
been disturbed from their slumber oshi's
group managed to take down their
opponents without losing single
man meanwhile are you shisha Carens the
other Ronin made their way through the
garden were fighting other gods in the
back of a house eventually the two
groups reunited and headed towards
Kira's private chambers together as I
use she predicted some of Kara's men
tried to make a getaway and bring word
to their masters father-in-law or a
Sunni sama who would have sent a small
army to eradicate the intruders
however they were all struck down by the
archers prowling the rooftops there
would be no help for Kira on that day
the fight went on until there were only
three of Kara's retainers left standing
but these were his best samurai they
were Kobayashi had Sharkey Waku hand IO
and Shimizu ikkaku they were all that
stood between the Ronin and Kira's
private room but they proved to be quite
a lot to handle the three expert
swordsman defended their points with
fierce intensity and even managed to
drive the Ronin back seeing that his men
were tired and starting to lose heart
Aisha shouted at them with rage they had
already forfeited their lives so why
were they shrinking in their resolution
now they should go in there and either
kill their opponents or die trying as
fulfilling their masters cause was the
noblest ambition of a retainer he then
commanded his son Chikara to go and
engage the three samurai in combat
the young man obeyed his father picking
up a spare and locked weapons with Waku
hand io febrile was too intense to be
contained in just one room and soon
enough the two were fighting in the
garden all seemed lost for the younger
he she went he tripped and fell into the
pond as Waku was getting ready to
deliver a killing blow
Chikara drew his sword and cut his
opponents leg causing him to fall the
Ronin then managed to get up and kill
Han died before he could retaliate when
he went inside he found that the rest of
the Ronin had finally dispatched the
other two swordsmen as well
there was nobody left to protect Kira
[Music]
they raided Kira's private chambers but
all they found were his son he willed it
a Harvard and tried in vain to defend
his position but he was too weak and
inexperienced to pose a real threat to
one Ronin let alone dozens of them yet
action was wounded but the samurai
allowed him to flee there was only one
target they had on their collective mind
so the search started for kira yoshinaka
their own in split into several small
parties and completely ransacked the
mansion but there was no trace of the
imperial official all they could find
were weeping women and children who in
accordance with Oishi's request were
left alone their own enveloped
despondent and at one point even
contemplated committing suicides then
and there as they feared they had failed
their mission however while going
through Kara's bedroom ie she felt that
his bed was still warm which meant that
he was sleeping in it when the attack
began kira to be somewhere near so they
started a new search this time around
four samurai were more fortunate one of
them made the inspired choice to take
down a large picture which was hanging
on the wall behind it they discovered a
secret tunnel which led outside to a
small courtyard where there was a
storage room for firewood and charcoal
at the other end of the tunnel there
were two more guards lying in wait but
they were no match and were quickly
struck down by the Ronin inside the
outhouse the samurai found an elderly
man in his sixties dressed as a noble
the man refused to give his name but the
Ronin were convinced that they had found
kairyushin naka ie she was able to
confirm the identity of the elderly
strange when he recognized the scar that
his master left him during his attack
that started this whole chain of events
despite the Ronan's hatred for this man
it was trumped by a Yi XI sense of
honour and respect that the traditions
of a samurai
he actually kneeled down and bowed his
head and deference to Kira and informed
him that they were the former retainers
of Asano nagging Orie and they were
there to seek justice for their master
he then gave the official the chance of
a nobleman's death by committing seppuku
according to some versions or he even
produced the same wakizashi that his
master had used better this may be one
of Mitford's added elements of traumatic
effect either way kira had no interest
in any kind of death so he kept begging
for mercy unsurprisingly given all they
went through this had no effect on the
Ronin eventually tiring of the old man's
plea
is she forced him on his knees and cut
off his head there Onan collected Gary's
head in a barkat and prepared to leave
but made sure to put out all of the
lights so as not to start a fire that
might damage the neighbor's houses
with their mission accomplished the 47
Ronin embarked on a new journey to
sengakuji in Takanawa where their
masters grave was located with the
intent of presenting Kira's head as an
offering and fulfillment of their duty
before turning themselves in there to
hurry word of their deed had spread
quickly throughout the town and when it
reached Lord sama he would have surely
sent his men to cut them down but they
soon discovered that apart from him
everyone else was very impressed with
their actions it was after all what was
expected of a true samurai word even
reached eight chief daimyo named mats
adhara a key former superior of the
Asano clan who was greatly pleased with
the Ronin and sent his own guards to
ensure their protection on the road to
Takanawa when the men reached the palace
of the Prince of sendai he do was
satisfied with their actions and invited
them to eat drink and rest before
continuing on their journey and so the
forty-seven Ronin reached their
destination safely and performed the
offering as they said prayers at their
masters tomb accepts that the
forty-seven Ronin were actually 46 one
of the Ronin named Terasaki gimon had
been absent from the procession to the
temple although what exactly had
happened to him remains something of a
mystery he didn't die in the fight and
he also didn't commit seppuku alongside
the rest of the Ronin
because he lived to the ripe old age of
83 Mitford makes no mention of him in
his version of events although
subsequent stories suggest that terasaka
because he was the lowest in rank was
dispatched as a messenger to travel to
the Akko domain and tellus Arno's family
what happens
however some historical documents
indicate that the Ronin mate was simply
fled before the attack and abandoned the
raid altogether which is why he wasn't
sentenced to death like all the others
this goes against the triumphant heroic
tale of the forty-seven Ronin though and
because there is nothing conclusive to
support it this part of the story
usually gets just forgotten in the
retellings as far as the other 46 Ronin
were concerned what's they expected to
happen it happens they were arrested and
sentenced to death
however because many saw their actions
as righteous and justified they were not
executed as criminals but were allowed
to commit seppuku
afterwards they were all buried at
sengakuji next to their lord the 47th
Ronin joined them
on his later death their graves became a
popular place of pilgrimage and one of
the many people who came to pay respects
was the same Satsuma man who once kicked
and spat on a ye she in the street when
he thought the Ronin had become a
drunkard unworthy of the name of samurai
he apologized for his insult and offered
atonement by taking out a dagger and
stabbing himself in the stomach dying in
front of a you--she's grave
this wasn't a unique case method also
mentions a samurai who almost 170 years
later committed seppuku before the grave
of Oishi Chikara because he was refused
entry into a clan in modern times there
is a festival at st. gaku temple every
December the 14th not as many cases of
suicide nowadays but people still turn
up to help commemorate the tale of the
forty-seven Ronin so I really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do hit that thumbs up button
below and don't forget to subscribe
brand new videos just like this every
day of the week for more from me why not
check out another channel I do cool
business blaze it's a little bit
different to this it's more casual
format and it's about business so in
fact it's completely different to this
but maybe you'll like it as well maybe
you won't you'll only find out if you
cook below and thank you for watching
[Music]